i wanted to like set it up so that i
could get laid without like having a
bunch of conversations and dates and
whatnot this is dan valzerian he's a
poker player businessman actor and
social media influencer known as the
king of instagram he lives a pretty
ridiculous life guns and girls blowing
stuff up stacks of cash and lavish
parties he certainly leads a
controversial yet enticing lifestyle
he's one of the most followed
personalities on social media with more
than 32 million instagram followers he
founded his own cannabis company and
even made a bid to run for president but
he's often come under fire for his
reckless behavior he got banned from a
miami nightclub for kicking a model in
the face he was also involved in a legal
dispute with a porn star after throwing
her off a roof from college dropout to
the king of instagram to being exposed
as a fraud
this is the rise and fall of dan
belzerian
dan bolzarian was born on december 7th
1980. his father paul bilzerian was a
well-known armenian-american businessman
and corporate takeover specialist dan
grew up in tampa florida in an 11
bedroom mansion with its own indoor
basketball court batting cage swimming
pool and lakefront views
after high school he enlisted in the
navy for four years and went directly
into seal training after completing two
hell weeks and 500 days of training dan
was dropped from the program for safety
violation two days before graduation
he received an honorable discharge and
spent the following four years at the
university of florida majoring in
business and criminology
by his second year he was broke he was
introduced to poker by his friends at
university but he needed money to gamble
so he sold off his guns and other
possessions
he apparently turned the 750 he had left
over from liquidating his possessions
into ten thousand dollars from playing
poker
he then bought a one-way ticket to las
vegas and turned that ten thousand
dollars into a hundred and eighty seven
thousand dollars
after his vegas trip he went back to
university more determined than ever he
resumed his studies while continuing to
hone his poker skills in cash games
after classes some weeks he claimed he
was making ninety thousand dollars he
was making so much money from playing
poker he realized that university was a
waste of time so he dropped out of
university and decided to become a
professional poker player
he claimed to have built his wealth from
playing poker but he hasn't appeared in
a lot of public tournaments his first
major appearance was back in 2009 when
he took part in the world series of
poker main event dan finished 180th
place and collected a prize of 36 000
his performance led to him signing a
sponsorship with victory poker an online
card room he allegedly received one
million dollars from the company for
wearing their name on a t-shirt for all
the tournaments he competed in that year
but despite his efforts victory poker
crumbled just after his one-year
contract with him had ended
dan apparently dedicated most of his
time and focus to private high-stakes
cash games with billionaires he has also
once claimed to have put all of his net
worth into one game and won big in 2013
he got people's attention when he posted
a tweet saying he had just won 10.8
million dollars in a private cash game
this win still hasn't been verified and
continues to be debated by many online
in 2015 dan hosted a poker tournament to
raise money for brain research the
tournament took place in his las vegas
home and had a buy-in of a thousand
dollars the tournament drew in a lot of
famous celebrities like steve aoki
ludacris and vin diesel and raised over
a hundred thousand dollars for brain
research according to dan himself the
most he has ever lost in a single game
of poker was 3.6 million dollars there
were also stories about dan betting 2.3
million dollars worth of chips on a
single coin toss and losing
dan's net worth is estimated to be
around a staggering 200 million dollars
and according to himself 50 million
dollars of that is from playing poker
he's most known for his insane lifestyle
models supercars private jets rpgs and
lavish parties the crazy stories just
keep coming his instagram has more
models than playboy and victoria's
secrets put together and that seems to
be the biggest reason for his fame
he apparently had a heart attack for
overdosing on viagra dan has admitted
that he had his first two heart attacks
at the age of 25 and had a total of
three heart attacks before the age of
32.
apparently after four days of binge
drinking and doing drugs dan ingested
about six times the recommended dose of
viagra to get things going downstairs
which resulted in a heart attack
he also bought his way into the armenian
army for a citizenship
upon joining the army dan celebrated the
feat by launching a bazooka he was once
also arrested by the los angeles police
department for a bomb making charge but
charges were later dropped
he has also been put on the
international wanted list by a court in
azerbaijan in early 2015 dan announced
that he would be running for president
he also vowed to give up sex drugs and
alcohol if he was elected
eventually he bound out of the race to
endorse donald trump who eventually went
on to win the presidency
in april 2014 dan was part of a photo
shoot that included the then 18 year old
porn star janice griffith
as part of the photo shoot he picked up
janice griffith and threw her off the
roof aiming for the pool beneath but his
throw was just a bit too short and she
hit the edge of the pool before falling
in the water griffith broke her foot and
the whole thing ended in a lawsuit in
december 2014 dan attended a nightclub
in miami to celebrate his 34th birthday
and for a yet undisclosed reason dan
decided to kick one of the women in the
face with his military boot he was also
involved in quite a massive story back
in 2011 alongside other celebrities like
toby maguire ben affleck and matt damon
a series of private high-stakes poker
games between the stars led to wins and
losses of millions of dollars the
problem was that one of the losers of
the games bradley ruberman paid his
losses with stolen money and was later
convicted
this led to a pile of lawsuits as
everyone attending these games tried to
get their money back
in october 2017 dan was present at the
horrific las vegas shooting when an
armed assailant opened fire on a group
of people from a hotel room all of whom
were attending a music festival
in true fashion he posted numerous
videos to his instagram account he was
seen searching a police car and asking
the officers for a gun
dan was widely criticized for his
actions and the way he handled himself
during that terrifying night
dan balzerian claimed that his wealth
was the outcome of a successful gambling
career however that claim has been
widely disputed some have speculated
that dan's wealth was instead inherited
from his father in 1989 paul bilzerian
was convicted of fraud and various
securities law violations
he was incarcerated in 1991 but was
smart enough to accumulate trust funds
for both sons dan and adam the trust
fund was believed to have had a
valuation of around 12 million dollars
in 1997 and has increased immensely ever
since
these funds are said to have played a
considerable part in dan's wealth
in 2017 dan started ignite international
brands a company self-described as a
global lifestyle brand unlike any other
the company sells cbd products vodka
nicotine-based vape pens and apparel
among other things the company is
probably best known for its over-the-top
launch parties that obviously seek to
give the attendees a glimpse into the
lifestyle they see on dan's instagram
djs models celebrities and enough
alcohol to intoxicate a small country
in january 2019 ignite raised 25.8
million during its initial public
offering but since their ipo the company
has had some serious problems resulting
in a sharp drop in its stock price in
the same year ignite recorded a loss of
around 50 million dollars this caused
turmoil between dan bilzerian and the
company's president curtis heffernan for
most of 2020 dan and his associates at
the knight were playing the blame game
trying to figure out who was at fault
for the continuous loss
to make matters worse mid-2020 saw the
release of a company report showing
numbers from ignite that some claim
proves that the company paid 67 million
dollars to fund dan balzerian's
lifestyle expenses such as two hundred
thousand dollars a month for his house
fifteen thousand dollars on a ping pong
table twenty six thousand dollars worth
of instagram promotions and a whopping
130 000 for a bahamas photo shoot
according to a lawsuit dan's mansion the
models the flights yachts were all
charged to the corporate tab of ignite
his six-figure lifestyle was basically
charged to a credit card that someone
else paid off in october of 2020 kanmart
one of ignite's main partners and
leading distributors in canada ended
their partnership this led to ignite
stock falling from 1.44 to just 36 cents
at the same time dan addressed these
allegations on his instagram story
referring to the head of ignite as an
idiot incompetent president and saying
that he had fired his ass
dan also added that he had put 25
million dollars of his own money into
the company
but according to heffernan he got fired
for blowing the whistle and telling the
company board about den's reckless
spending the company seems optimistic
about his prospects and it seems that
dan balzerian's brand might be here to
stay
most recently he's moved out of his 200
000 per month mansion and despite all
the controversy he still has an
estimated net worth of 200 million
dollars and continues to live a pretty
lavish lifestyle
the millionaire playboy is regularly
seen on social media flaunting yachts
private jets cars guns and holidays his
company ignite seems to be going
downhill again but dan expects his
company to gross billions of dollars and
hopes to donate a large portion of it to
charity he recently self-published a
book titled the setup which is an ode to
himself and the philosophy to which he
attributes his success
part memoir part guide to achieving the
lifestyle
in the spirit of neil strauss's pickup
artist bible titled the game dan's book
is essentially an unfiltered version of
his life in print
with regards to the mysterious origins
of his fortune he was born into wealth
so there's no question that he's a
certified trust fund baby
it's quite clear to see that his fortune
did in fact come from his father's trust
fund it's on public record so there's
absolutely no denying the fact that dan
used that money to build his wealth
but he's often gone on social media to
defend himself and just covers it all up
with a mountain of lies
ultimately it's unknown whether he
actually bought a one-way ticket to las
vegas and turned that ten thousand
dollars into a hundred and eighty seven
thousand dollars or whether he actually
won 10.8 million dollars in a private
cash game as most of his claims are
anecdotal
what we do know is that he still has
plenty of money to play with
there's a lesson in every story
what can we learn from dan balzerian's
rise to fame
he's a provocative and controversial
character from his playboy lifestyle to
throwing a porn star of a roof to
starting a company to self-publishing a
book to lying about the origins of his
fortune it's easy to hate him
far from an inspiring ranks to riches
story he basically flexed his way to
worldwide fame
but nonetheless he's got everyone
talking he's managed to use his fortune
and crafted one of the most outrageous
instagram pages and even got dubbed the
king of instagram
by living such a ridiculous life and
building a massive following on social
media he's managed to leverage his
wealth into worldwide fame
and much like other controversial
celebrities he's managed to build
businesses off the back of that
ultimately making him incredibly rich
and successful
is he just a typical trust fund baby or
is there a sliver of truth behind his
successful gambling career the comment
section in this one will be very
interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one